[Müzik]
Merhaba Hoş geldiniz Onur Gökçek Ben
tedx olduğum için çok mutluyum Beni niye
çağırdılar diye biraz düşündüm Çok
konuştuğum için olabilir gerçekten çok
konuşuyorum
konsepti konuşmak olan programa davet
edilmem çok normal geldi 6 aylıktan beri
konuşuyorum yani 6 aylıkken konuşmuşum
resmi ilk meme demişim Hala da Aynı
fikirdeyim
Bugün de sorsan yine Mehmet ederim
6 aylıkken Vermiş olduğum kararların ne
kadar doğru olduğunu bugün burada bir
kere daha görüyorum Gerçekten çok
konuşuyorum ben konuşurken birçok şey
bitti film izliyorsan Film bitti Spor
yapılıyorsa Spor bitti yemek yiyorsa
Yemek bitti Hesap ödendi Bu iyi bir şey
bir kere bir arkadaşım ben konuşurken
araya girmeye çalıştı lafını balla
kesiyorum dedi kesemedi O kadar çok
konuşuyorum sevmiyorum konuşmayı
konuşmakla beraber yani bir de sıkıntılı
bir adam benim çok konuşuyorum hem
çirkinim hem takıntılıyım bir sürü şeyi
birleşmiş annem ben bana hamileyken
sancılanıyor hastaneye kaldırıyorlar
doğum çok yaklaştığı bir süreçte 9
aylıkken doğum gerçekleşmiyor annemi
yatırıyorlar o gece orada babam Saat iki
gibi geç oldu ben gideyim demiş
Annem de çok bozulmuş yıllarca anlattı
yapıyor ha dedi Çok acayip içimde kaldı
O laf benim bilmem ne Ben Sonradan
anladım saatle alakalı değil abi bana
artık ileri görüşlü anlamış geliyor bu
herif artık çok geç artık çok geç ben
gideyim Yapacak bir şey yok bence
durdurmaya çalıştım doğru mu
durduramadım geldim dünyaya söylediğim
gibi çirkinim de çirkinliğimi kapatmak
için saçımı uzattım
gözlük var sakal bıraktım karizmatik
olsun diye gel sakalıyken karizmatik
olduğum tek ben düşünüyorum Bunu
biliyorum genelde karizmatik olduğum bir
tek ben düşünüyorum Hatta düşünce ben
bile Düşünmüyorum yani karizmatik olarak
geçirdiğim olanlara dönüp bakıyorum Evet
olur Orada da karizmatik değilmişsin
diyorum küçüklüğümden beri böyle 10-11
yaşındaydım mahallemize gelen Sonya diye
bir kıza asılıyorduk Emrah diye bir
arkadaşımla asılıyorduk dedim kabat
abiyle söylüyorum masum bir şey son ya
da 11 yaşında Biz de 11 yaşındayız Emrah
da sürekli kapışıyoruz Sonya Senin
sevgilin benim sevgilim bir gün böyle
Sony aramızda onu etkilemeye çalışıyoruz
Emre hakkında şöyle bir şey yaptı Songül
dedi şöyle Bana bak kime benziyorum dedi
kız şöyle baktı kime dedi Van'dayım dedi
kızı etkiledi tamam mı 11 yaşındayız
bende böyle Altta kalmak için hemen
Araya girdim dedim Sonra şöyle Bana bak
bakalım Ecevit'e benziyor muyum ben
benim karizmadan aldığım bu
çirkinim biliyorum çünkü sahneye çıkıp
çirkin diye şaka yapıyorum yıllardır
içinizden bir kişi bile Estağfurullah
demiyor
sahneye çıkıp çirkin diye şaka yapıyorum
içinizden bir kişi bile Estağfurullah
demiyor diyorum yine de içinizden bir
kişi bile Estağfurullah demiyor
ne kadar haklı olduğumu görüyorsunuz
sonra diyorlar ki çok çirkinlikten
bahsediyorum Ne yapayım
filmle ilgili en iyi yiyorum ama
işlerinden Zehra diye bir arkadaşım
yaptı bir gün böyle ben sahnede Beni
izlemeye geldiler çalıştığım dönemde iş
yerinden çirkinlik falan anlattım
sahnede ertesi gün iş yerine geldi Zehra
dedi ki Oğlum dedi Sen dedi dün
çirkinlik falan diye anlatıyorsun ama
dedi baktığın zaman dedi boylu postlu
adamsın dişlerin dediği inci gibi
gözlerin dedi kocaman badem gibi
dudaklarını dedi köfte gibi ama hepsi
bir araya gelince bir boka benzemiyor
oğlum dedi
tek tek güzel organların var da tek
surat için değil
Ulan Üzüleyim mi bilemedim kabardım
çöktüm
benle ilgili en iyi tespiti yine
işlerinden servis şoförümüz yaptı Çünkü
amca 70 yaşında emekli bekçi iyi bir
referans gibi durmuyor ama güzel
konuştum
alta dolu konuştu yani bana bir gün dedi
ki olur dedi Sen çok iyi bir çocuksun
dedi böyle serviste gidiyoruz Nereden
biliyorsun dedim yiyip çocuk olduğunu ve
tanışalı da bir iki hafta olmuş yani
emekli bekçi Ya insan sarrafiyim ayağımı
yapıyor bana dedim nereden biliyorsun
çok iyi bir çocuk olduğumu oğlum dedi
hem çirkinsin hem paran yok senin bu
dünyada iyi olmaktan başka şansın yok
tutunamazsın dost edinemezsin dedim çok
mantıklı gerçekten çok mantıklı Biz
çirkinler İyi olmak zorundayız
zaten bir adam hem çirkin hem fakir hem
de kötüyse gerçekten kötüdür net kötüdür
yani bunu bilinçli olarak yapıyordur çok
zor çirkin ve fakir olmak Çünkü tam
tersi insanlarla hayatlarımızda zengin
ve yakışıklı ben onlarla iletişim
kuramadım bir dönem özellikle Emre diye
bir arkadaşım var Bir gün doğum günü
orada fark ettim Aradım çocuğu temennide
bulunamadım diyecek hiçbir şey bulamadım
Doğum günün kutlu olsun Her şey Görünce
zaten öyle süper mutlu biraz zaten öyle
diyecek hiçbir şey yok Her şey zaten
öyle
iki saniye sürüyor telefon konuşması
doğum günü kutlu olsun deyip Kapatıyorum
o beni bir arıyor 25 dakika öyle olsun
böyle olsun olsun
ölümlü dünya arada ölümü de katıyor
Çünkü bulunduğum durumun Bir tık altı
ölüm tamam mı biliyor bunu yavaş yavaş
alıştırmaya çalışıyor beni
zor zor gerçekten
zor yani bir de aynı zamanda söylediğim
gibi takılayım şöyle takıntılar
benim için çok normal şeyler ama
sonradan yıllar sonra anladım ki
insanlar için bunlar hastalıkmış yani
Mesela arabayı park ettim kapıyı
kapattım pencerelere elimle baktım
kapıların Hepsini elimde kontrol ettim
Sokağın başından dönerim acaba Radyo
açık kaldı aküm bitecek çok önemli değil
döner bakalım ya da işte evde kapılar
pencereler her yere kontrol ettim Çıktım
Sokağın başından dönerim acaba
YouTube'da kaldı yangın mı çıkacak
önemli değil dönüyorum biliyorum Bir
haftadır ütü yapılmıyor gene de
dönüyorum bir yerde duruyor alıp onu
balkona koyuyorum kendi kendine yanacak
gibi geliyor takıntılar bilirler ütü
bizim en büyük düşmanımız
var yani yok edebilirim ütüyü
Bunlar çok sıradan şeyler bunlar alıştım
bunlarla yaşıyorum gerçekten hiç
hayatımı zorlamıyor Çünkü gerçekten uzun
yıllar böyle yaşayınca normalleşiyor
beni rahatsız eden bir tane var Ocak
takıntım ocağa karşı ayrı bir takıntım
var Her akşam yatmadan 15-20 dakika
ocağa Baktım oluyor
orada şöyle bir şey oluyor Şimdi
yatmadan Evdeki her yeri kontrol ettim
kapılar prizler pencereler baktım en son
mutfağa giriyorum mutfakta da şöyle bir
şey var şimdi mutfakta işte dolap priz
Mizgin oraya bakıyorum finalde ocağa
geliyorum ocakta bir iki üç dört tane
tuş var gazın çıktı hepsini kapatıyorum
bir de vana var çift dönmem onu da
kapatıyorum buradan kaçarsa oradan
kaçmasın diye Sonra bakıyorum 1 2 3 4
kapalı vana Kapalı kapalı kapalı bana
zaten kapalı bunu hem görüyorum hem
söylüyorum zaten net olarak kapalı belli
yani kapalı olduğu zaten bunun bu da
kapalı bunu hem görüyorum hem söylüyorum
bu da kapalı kapalı
kokluyorum Evet kapalı net olarak kapalı
15-20 dakika böyle baktığım oluyor sonra
Diyorum ki acaba beynin bana bir oyun
oynuyor olabilir mi
Çünkü o kadar çok kapalı kapalı değilim
ki gözüm Belki de beynime kafalısın ya
da gönderiyor belki kafalı değil Nereden
bileceğim bilemezsin
ben bundan çıkamıyordum gerçekten
yıllarca bu döngüye gittim Sonra ben
bunu bir yerde anlattım bir tane kız
arkadaş el kaldırırsa arasında dedi ki
bende de vardı çözdüm dedi hiç de
inanmadım nasıl dedim çok kolay
fotoğrafını çekiyorum dedi
dedim Ne güzel çek fotoğrafını git
yatakta bak Anasını satayım Kapalı
kapalı kapalı kapalı
eyvallah
[Alkış]
yine bakıyorum ama daha konforlu daha
konforlu bir de benim için iyi olduğunu
düşündüğüm bir takıntım var hastalık
takıntım bunu seviyorum hasta olmamaya
karşı takıntılıyım bana ne başkası olsun
gibi bir şey sevmiyorum olmayı elimden
geleni yapıyorum Gerçekten
tanıyanlar bilirler düzenli spor yaparım
her gün meyve yerim proteini böyle
direkt yumurtanın beyazını sarıdan
ayırıp balla sütle karıştırıp içelim
falan çok ciddi kendime bakıyorum ama ne
yaparsan yap bazen hasta oluyorsun ya
kaçamıyorsun o böyle bir şey geliyor ya
boğazını önceden böyle bir pislik
anlıyorsun o olduğu an bir ağrı kesici
bir antibiyotik bir grip ilacı atıyorum
bütün gün çay Ihlamur portakal soruları
akşama kadar sıcak şeyler Akşam
yemeğinde bir tavuk suyu çorba içiyorum
karabiberle limonlu Yatmadan bir ağrı
kesici bir antibiyotik bir girebilecek
atıyorum üstüne bir tane eleman kaynatıp
bir çakıyorum hastalık diyor ki Allah
belanı versin ya sen diyor Ne illet bir
adamsın diyor
vücudumu terk edip gidiyor Sonuçta
mikrofonda barınmaya ihtiyacı var
vücudunda çok tutmuyorum 4 gibi hasta
olup akşam 9 gibi misafirlere
gitmişliğin var yani kendime bak
ama bir işe yaramıyor arkadaşlar tetiks
olduğu için burada söyleyeyim Hani
Şuradan Bunu anlayın Gerçekten hiçbir
faydası yok Tek faydası komedyen olduğum
için belki de işime yarıyor anlatıyorum
Onun dışında bir faydası yok yani son
3-4 senedir hayatla ilgili hayata
bakışın biraz korku biraz ümit genel
olarak Rahat olmak bunu sağlamaya
çalışıyorum rahatlık çok önemli Pimpirik
bir işe yaramıyor mesela eski çalıştığım
yerde
bundan önce başka bir şey anlatayım
Tamam vazgeçtim Ondan sonra geleyim
koşmaya gidiyorum Bir gün evden çıktım
dedim Hiçbir şey almayayım kimliği
alayım Şimdi Düşer Düşer daha rahat
koşarım kimliği aldım çıkacağım Bu yeni
çıkan kimlikler biliyorum bakanlıktan
geliyor parmak izi ile alıyorsun
kaybolunca yok işte para cezası var ya
dedim şimdi düşebilir bu tedirgin oldum
eski kimliği vermemiştim dedim eski
kimliği alayım O daha değersiz onu aldım
tam çıkacağım evden falan dedim Öğrenci
kimliğim var benim evde onu alayım
çıkamıyorum evden anladığım öyle
Öğrenci kimliğini aldım çıktım düştü
hiçbir faydası yok boşu boşuna
pimpiliklenmeyin çok düşünce bir şey
değişmiyor
Bir de çok buluyor işte eski çalıştığım
iş yerinde dediğim bir öbek kafa işte
böyle 100 kişilik Orada iki tarafta
tuvalet vardı kadın erkek karışık tekli
Yani önemli de yok Genelde dolu tek
kişilik olduğu için kalabalık bir ofise
yetmiyor sıra var neyse bir gün gittim
tuvalete girdim boş çok mutlu oldum
kapıyı kapattım arkadaş aldı dedim Dolu
girdim tuvalete klozet TV açtım İğrenç O
kadar kötü bırakmış ki Böyle midem
bulandı aynı şeyi sorguladım Allah'ım
dedim ne biçim iş Bu vejeteryanlar
haklıymış falan kapattım
yapılacak gibi değil çıkayım bari dedim
tam çıkacağım kapıda adam var benden
bilecek
Ortada hiçbir sebep yok sebep yokken
şerefsizin birinin bokunu temizlerken
Buldum kendimi köpürte köpürte her yeri
temizledim ıslak mendillerle o kılları
malıları Aynen oraları böyle cillop gibi
yaptığım çıktım takıntılıyım biliyorsun
bana kalacak ben onunla yaşayamam
buluyor o yüzden arkadaşlar rahat olun
Bir de fiyatlarına baktım şöyle gelmeden
genelde zengin insanlar burada varlıklı
insanlar çok mutlu oluyorum sizinle
beraber olduğum için ben çünkü hala taze
Garibim o parayı bulduğundaki parayı
bulamadım
ama zengin arkadaşlarım var Yaptığım
işten dolayı çok en son dönemlere çok
fazla zengin ve varlıklı arkadaşım var
ve onlarla yaşıyorum o yüzden zengin
gibi yaşayabiliyorum bende yani onlarla
takıldığım sürece zengin hayatı
yaşıyorum biraz karakterden ödün vermen
gerekiyor ama o kadar Şaka yapıyorum
şaka bayağı ödün vermen gerekiyor
baya Onlar ne ediyor sonra yiyorum ne
içerse onu içiyorum Hiç İtiraz etmiyorum
tatile mi gideceğiz onların istediği
yere gidiyorum ama sonuçta zaten zengin
gibi yaşamak istiyorsan onların
yaptıklarını hayal ediyorsan
yaşatıyorlar Yani bir sorun yok
yaşıyorum geçen şöyle bir şey oldu Beni
zengin iftarına çağırdı arkadaşlarımdan
bir tanesi
Ben ilk defa böyle bir iftara gittim
onlarla çok restorana gittim bir Fransız
restoranda ya birçok kişi oruçlu değildi
ama Ramazan'da olduğu için bu yemek Hani
kültürde olduğu için iftara denk
getirelim oruçlularda orucunu açar falan
diye böyle bir yemek düzenlemişler iftar
Ben mahalleden Serkan diye bir
arkadaşını da aldım yanıma o da dedim
nasiplensin garibim
Abi çok garip bir yemekti mesela Fransız
restorana gitmiş olanlar bilirler böyle
birazcık ekstra bir İhtişam var herhalde
orada gerçekten çok lükse Çünkü şöyle
bir şey oldu ezan masada okundu
Adamın biri gelip masada suratıma Ezan
okudu benim
böyle tedirgin oldum yani böyle
izleniyormuş gibi hani oruçta Tutmuyorum
Bir yandan zaten Tedirginim Adam en son
okudu bitirdi Serkan da Allah kabul
etsin dedi bir kişi Amin demedi
Abi bir de yemekten önce sürekli yemek
geliyor biliyorsun Orada öyle
restoranlarda portakallı bir şey geliyor
kızarmış ekmeği bir şey sürüp
gönderiyorlar Pizza geliyor geliyordu ha
babam geliyor Ben kurmasın Biliyorum çok
yemiyorum ki yemeği yerim Serkan
Durmadan yiyor Ne gelse sildi süpürdü
benimkileri de yemeye başladı ya bir ara
şöyle bir şey dedi salçalı ekmek alayım
bir tane daha dedi adama oğlum salçalık
ekmek dedi bambaşka bir şey Muhtemelen
de
dedim ki yapma Serkan yemek yiyemezsin
yok dedi yerim oğlum işte yememen lazım
utanıyorum yapma
Garson bu arada garsonları da çok garip
her bir şey bıraktığında teşekkür
ediyorlar bir şey bırakıyor Teşekkür
ederim efendim geri çekiyorum teşekkür
etmesi gereken kişi biziz sen değilsin
çok garip yani orada dönen Dünya
Neyse zaten şeyde kalkmamız lazımdı
finalde finalde ben bunları çözdük bu
kadar Ezanlar okundu yemekler yerinde
kimse Amin nefret dedim ya Serkan
doyunca Çok da mutlu oldun Split ederken
dedi ki Allah herkese böyle bir arkadaş
nasip etsin dedi herkes amin dedi
lan dedim Bir de paranın dedim yok
diyorsunuz var mı oğlum çaktırmadan
mesaj vermeye çalışıyorum çünkü bana
komedi yap dediler yapacak bir şey yok
niye tetikse geldim Bunu düşündüm dün
gece burada bir Otelde kaldım niye
geldim
tabi birileri çağırdı Sağ olsunlar Davet
ettiler güzel bir etkinlik Bunların
hepsi bir sebep Ama asıl sebebi benim
ben istediğim için geldim burada olmak
beni mutlu ettiği için geldim Çünkü ben
de herkes gibi bencilim ben de bencilce
yaşıyorum kendimi düşünerek kendim
geleceğimi düşünüyorum Başka bir şey
düşünmüyorum veya başka şeyler için
mücadele etmiyorum diye düşündüm biraz
bunun üstüne düşündüm Aslında
bencillik üstüne de düşündüm Bununla
ilgili de biraz düşündüm
Dün gece düşündüm bunların hepsini
bencilliği Savunmuyorum Benim de
inandığım Benim de inandığım bir hayat
inandığım bir gelecek inandığım bir
ülkeye kendi fikirlerim siyasi görüşüm
var ama hep şey düşünüyorum bunlar için
mücadele edip Ben kazansam bile
istediğim olsa bile gelecekteki Onur
yaşta onur ve o başka bir şey düşünüyor
olacak o bundan mutlu olmayacak şu an
istediklerim o zaman istemiyor olacak o
olur Peki o zaman niye mücadele edeyim
ki dedim belki şey diyor olabilirsiniz
Yani sen de bencillik yapma o zaman
Başkaları için bir şey yap gelecek
nesiller için bir şey yap Birincisi ya
benimki Bencillik değil ya Başkaları
için bir şey yapmak da bencillik Çünkü
Başkaları için bir şey yapmak senin
mutlu etmiyor olsaydı kılın kıpırdamazdı
Onlar bunu yapmak seni mutlu ettiği için
yapıyorsun Herkes kendini mutlu etmek
için bir şey yapıyor Herkesin bir
mücadelesi var Kimisi siyasi Kimisi
komedi yapıyor Kimisi
oyun oynuyor gibi spor yapıyor
bilmiyorum Herkes kendi mutlu etmeye
çalışıyor şunu da diyebilirsin o da
kendini mutlu etmeye çalışıyor Sen de
kendini mutlu etmeye çalışıyorsun ama
finalde o başkalarına faydalı oluyor Sen
olmuyorsun diyebilirsin doğru Ama
başkalarına faydalı olmak ne kadar doğru
bunu çok kestiremiyorum Çünkü spesifik
örnek belki Aziz Nesin de insanlara
faydalı olmak için çok mücadele etti bir
sürü insan böyle mücadele etti bugün
kalkıp baksa Damacana tecavüz eden adamı
görse Şu ülkenin halini görse sokak
röportajları görse bileklerini Keser Ben
bunlar için mücadele etmişim diye O
yüzden korkuyorum mücadelecilikten
kaçıyorum Tabii ki de eyvallah bir kişi
alkışladı oğlum Bir Tek Sen tembelsin
benim gibi gerçekten mücadele etmemiz
lazım Şaka yaptım çünkü bana Gerçekten
şaka yaptım dediler alta dolu bir şey
Konuşmayı çok istedim ama dedim dediler
ki hayır sen komedi yap Emin misiniz
dedim Bakın Ona göre bir şeyler de
söyleyebilirim çok Benim de istediğim
şeyler var Hayır dediler ben de böyle
çaktırmadan dolu konuşmaya çalıştım ama
durmak yok mücadeleye devam
beni buraya çağırdığı için dedik
ailesine Çok teşekkür ediyorum Siz de
dinlediğiniz için teşekkür ediyorum
galiba Onur Gökçek
[Alkış]